We have a voicemail number. That number
is two one nine two. David P. This is a
caller this is our biblical prophecy caller.
She's called in many times over the years
and she analogizes the news into biblical
prophecy in a way that, for me is completely
disconnected from reality and irrelevant.
But it's still interesting. Apparently,
Biden defeating Trump has thrown biblical
prophecy into chaos. Take a listen to this.
I have bad news for you. I felt for a long time
that Bush was the writer on the fiery red
horse. Obama was right to the dark horse,
right in Revelations, Apocalypse Four
Horsemen, Chapter six, and that Trump
is the writer on the Pale Horse. And because he
lost the election series follows close behind
is Biden. I think he wants a war against Israel
because he ran with Obama and so he would be pro
pro Islam. And I think he's going to kill
Christians and hunger and peace. And that's
covid and something else that I can't remember.
Yeah. So whatever that goes on for two more
minutes. So so listen, I mean, that that's
a framework. That's a framework. And I
know that it's easy to laugh it off,
but that's a framework that actually
appeals to a lot of people in the United States
seeing things through that lens. I think it's
completely counterproductive beyond just not
being based, in fact. But I do for some reason.
I find it like I find that call fascinating.
I think the pale horse and killing Christians.
I am fascinated that that is a framework that
some people find find reasonable. But, you know,
to each their own, as I say, let's remind you
that we have a tremendous bonus bonus show.
Oh, boy. We have a tremendous bonus
show for you today. We will talk about
a Trump donor wanting his money back and
much, much more get instant access to the
I have to be careful here bonus show by
becoming a member at join Pakman Dotcom.